I love you because of
your money. Yeah. $43.
Can we go first? Yeah.
Okay. So does that mean
I think you
fix her hair?
Uh, I think well first thing that
comes to mind is just best friends.
Exactly. Even though it's like the
cheesiest thing in the world. Um,
well I didn't think it was a real thing
until we did it because we were actually
best friends before,
before we did it. Yeah.
So it was just this weird like seamless
transition thing. But um, I dunno.
Weird. We're very weird. Yes. Yeah.
Can you hear me?
I Hate Chicago. Okay. Yeah, no. See
my very,
very first impression of her,
I thought she was really
cute and she was super fun.
But then my next impression of her was
a few months later when I moved in with
her best friend and that's when
I like really got to know her.
I don't like your haircut.
Sorry.
You're saying something Sassy right now.
So actually I hate telling us because
it sounds so like gross and millennial,
but the first time I ever saw him was on
my snapchat story. It wasn't until like
six months later maybe that he
randomly moved in with my best friend.
We just started hanging out
as friends and became really,
really good friends and it was
just this super platonic thing.
Um,
well I told them when I first saw you,
and it was on my friend's snapchat story,
such a millennial news.
It was August 8th, 2016. Um,
and we went to Sushi stop afterwards we
walked to Gelson's and bought Oreos and
then came back to my apartment
and watched stranger things.
I think our first date was
a at Sushi stop. August 8th,
uh, 20. What's this year?
[inaudible] 16, I think.
Yeah. And then we stopped into the
grocery store right across the street,
got a pack of Oreos and then went back
to his place and watch stranger things.
What'd you say?
Oh,
I said our first date was
August 8th, 2016. Nice, Nice.
Let's see if she stopped. Yeah.
Did you tell him about the Oreos?
Okay, I'm glad I got the show right. Wow.
Oh Man. I guess the first
thing, she's so funny.
Then she'll like,
she'll be honest with you.
She'll give you great advice and she'll
give you like advice to,
to better you as a person.
Ah, I don't know. He
is the nicest guy in the world.
Um,
he's really, uh, has no shame
in just a way that's like,
he is super,
completely himself all the time,
which is unreal and cool
and I love that about him.
And um, he makes me
laugh. He's really funny,
but I'm not going to tell him myself
that because then he'll get cocky.
So I said, you had no shame like
in just being yourself wherever,
whenever,
which I think is cool.
Cool. I said you were super funny.
Wow. First thing I said, I mean,
so I said you were funny.
Really don't just calm down.
She has like seven Billy and
red notifications on her phone
and it didn't dry.
Like I,
if I have like one unread email I have
to like get rid of it and she has like
6.5 million emails and like 48
notifications from some random APP.
She now two ways. Um,
but that's not, I mean,
I dunno. It's like, you know, is
anything, it is kind of funny. Um,
but she's also a really great front seat
driver and she gets a little nervous
when I get close to cars
and stuff like that.
He, this is just going
to reflect poorly on me,
but he just touches me way too much.
But like his love language is physical
touch and mine's do I get really hot
really easily.
So sometimes I'll just be sitting
there like in my own sadness and hot,
just this awful thing and, and he'll
like come up and like try to like,
you know, touch me or something like
that and I'm like, you gotta stop it.
You can't do that. This is another
thing that's like a good thing.
But he never gets angry.
Just let it out sometimes.
You know? Uh, we were on the way
here and I was telling him like,
who will sit in a lane of traffic that
is not moving while the lane next to him
is just zooming by because he's just
like content with wherever he's at,
which is great.
I, there was one part where
I knew what you were saying.
I'm hot touch you all the time.
I knew it was my science. I
said he touches me too much.
I would just say, yeah. Uh,
I said that you have like 60 billion
unread notifications on your phone.
It's true.
God.
And that doesn't mean that you're
a fantastic front seat driver.
I told him you're not aggressive
enough like rep rose. All right.
I probably look bad because my thing
was I was just complaining about things
that are like good qualities to have
as a human being, you know?
Oh, he's two functioning.
He doesn't get angry, you
know, like don't do it.
But yeah,
wait a beat. Great. Stop.
Um, no, we,
I mean we honestly really haven't had
like a big fight or something like crazy,
like scary thing or whatever
in a previous relationship.
Um,
but I had been,
someone had been disloyal to me to
say politely and so I had like not,
it wasn't,
I wouldn't say trust issues,
but I was like pretty insecure about
and just other guys in general.
And I would just,
it was like in my head that something bad
would happen if like she got too close
to another guy or something like that.
I think it was kind of a good thing
that we like had these, you know,
sometimes arguments or fights or whatever
about like this insecurity that I had
to get over. And you know, she
was actually really great with it.
He had some trust issues at the
beginning of the relationship.
He didn't even, he was like,
I don't want to be that guy.
I don't, I don't, you know,
I want you to hang out with your friends.
I don't even care.
But for some reason like it's
bothering me and I can't, you know.
And so that was just something we had
to work through a little bit because I
don't think I gave him enough
grace in the beginning of that. Um,
because I had a really hard time
understanding why it was happening.
I said when I was like annoying and
I said the same thing but not
in those words. Nice. Yeah.
It's really truly almost hard
to explain like everyone,
like has this like ideal person and like,
it's like a sheet of like kind of things
you think you want in a person, um,
or you think you need an a person.
And then once you meet like the one that
just exceeds all of those expectations
and like every way possible.
I just,
I wake up every day,
like truly want just wanting
to be hers or be with her,
hang out with her,
spend time with her or you know,
do something for her.
I love who she makes me
and I love who she is and,
and how she makes me a better person.
And just,
uh,
it yourself,
um,
who have like, no, he's
gonna make it worse.
Uh,
yeah,
this start to finish.
She's like as perfect
as you could get for me.
And that includes all of her,
her flaws and her accepting single one
of my flaws and me for everything that I
am,
I can never find someone like her.
I don't think there's anyone
better out there for me.
So
I never have to be afraid of introducing
them to someone because I know that
they're going to like him
because everyone does. Gosh,
he's just so sweet and caring and loving,
like just so loving,
you know,
so much so that I get
annoyed by it sometimes,
but he really wants me to love myself,
really shows me how I now
believe I deserve to be loved.
I don't know. I just, I'm so bad though.
Uh, but you know, he, he's
so good. Okay. I'm done now.
I can't, I can't do this anymore. It
freaks you out. Okay. You're done now.
So what'd you say?
I said that I love you
because of your money.
Yeah.
$43.
Nice honey. I said, I said, I, uh,
I love you because you're, um, I love it
cause you're such a good person and I
never have to worry about introducing you
to people because everybody loves you
and just
how well you love me
and how well you show me
how to love myself. And um, I don't know.
You're just God's gift to the world.
I guess
everyone has this like sheet of like
boxes that kind of you think need to be
checked in,
like someone that,
whether it's like a type or like
physically or emotionally or mentally or
whatever personality wise,
and just like meeting you was like
exceeding all those expectations and you
almost like don't know what to do with
it. Bottom line. I'm great. Yes, exactly.
Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, yeah.
You're a funny guy.
Thanks brother.
All right. Sorry, I'm
the battle. Ooh, sick.
Hey guys,
this is Jason.
Would you believe we just want to say
thank you for this beautiful couple for
sharing, right? Well, Jason,
Troy and Piper drying both sides.
I love story. Uh, as always, please make
sure to check them out on Instagram,
on Youtube.
Make sure you like and
subscribe the Jubilee Media
and we will see you next time.
Please.